today on the matt walsh show it could be
a babylon b headline but it's tragically
real the state department issued a
statement yesterday calling for the
taliban to be inclusive and
representative our country is run by
people who are completely out of touch
with all semblance of reality we can't
hope to solve afghanistan's problems if
we can't solve that problem we'll talk
about that also joe biden makes his
excuses in a speech yesterday he's been
roundly panned for the speech and for
good reason but was he actually right
about some of what he said we'll discuss
and the governor of tennessee tells the
state's public schools that they cannot
issue mass mandates then nashville
schools say hey we're going to do it
anyway and in our daily cancellation
we'll talk about lizzo's claims that her
critics are fat phobic sexist and racist
all of that and more today on the matte
wall show
you know what i really don't like it's
uh feeling nauseous it's a terrible
feeling i just my personal view
viewpoint i'm not imposing on anybody
else but my personal view is is i don't
like feeling sick but sometimes i do
especially when i'm in the car you know
if i have to god forbid take an uber
which these days costs 40 to go about
five miles so i try not to uh but i i
struggle with car sickness which is why
i'm always making sure that i bring with
me my trusty relief band which is the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that has been clinically
proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraine hangover morning sickness
chemotherapy and so much more the
product is drug free which is great even
better it's non-drowsy some of those
other anti-nausea medications you might
find at the gas station or something
they don't work as well and also they're
gonna put you to sleep and you might not
be in a situation where you can go right
to sleep especially if you're you know
driving or something relief ben is the
only over-the-counter wearable device
that has been used in hospitals and
oncology clinics to treat nausea and
vomiting so you know it works so you can
ensure that nausea is never the reason
to miss out on life's important moments
right now relief ban has an exclusive
offer just for matt walsh listeners if
you go to reliefband.com your promo code
wall should receive 20 off plus free
shipping and no questions asked 30-day
money-back guarantee so head to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com and use our
promo code walsh for 20 off
we begin today with uh some good news a
job opportunity in an up-and-coming
sector the job search site day book has
this help wanted ad posted by the united
nations entity for gender equality and
the empowerment of women also known as
u.n women for short in what appears to
be a very real listing un women is
calling for a partnership specialist to
advance gender equality and women's
empowerment
in kabul afghanistan
it says that the length of the initial
contract will be one year which
conveniently is also the life expectancy
of whoever takes the job there's no
information on on how the position
became available we can use our
imagination and also we're not told
anything about the dress code which at
this point we can assume is probably
restrictive but it does say that the key
traits needed for this job are respect
for diversity integrity professionalism
and of course a death wish um i trust
that a whole flock of pink haired antifa
feminists will be applying for this job
at once i mean why wouldn't they
there's plenty of misogyny to fight in
afghanistan plenty of fascism to fight
i'm sure they'll be on the first plane
over there
if they can find a flight that goes in
now in fairness we can maybe assume
maybe maybe that this listing was posted
before the events of the last few days
that would make it slightly less crazy
that assumption though may be
giving too much credit to the brain dead
bureaucrats who are currently running
the entire western world after all it
was just yesterday that a spokesman for
the state department a man appropriately
named ned
got up in front of cameras and said this
additionally the u.n security council
issued a joint press statement earlier
today calling for a new government that
is united
inclusive
and representative including with the
full and
full and meaningful participation of
women
the council spoke with one voice to
underscore that afghanistan must abide
by its international obligations
including to international humanitarian
law and ensure the safety and security
of all afghans and international
citizens
well
ned has spoken ladies and gentlemen not
just ned from the state department but
all of the nets of the u.n security
council they have all spoken in one
voice the taliban must
must we say must
be representative and inclusive we not
only demand that the 7th century
barbarian horde currently running
afghanistan must tolerate women but they
must in fact include women in their
government
now i know what you're thinking i know
you think you're thinking this is
outrageous this is stupid this is
embarrassing this is insane i mean how
could they tell the taliban to respect
women
and not mention that they should also
represent and include members of the
lgbt community you know
how is the state department to this
point not so much as suggested that the
taliban consider appointing a trans
woman as a warlord of some village
somewhere at a minimum
well don't worry they'll get around to
that i'm sure for now the focus is on
insisting that men who literally cover
their women in burlap sex
must magically leave those old ways
behind and embrace western egalitarian
principles
what if they don't
well i'll tell you what happens if they
don't the state department will monitor
the situation and they stand ready at a
moment's notice to meet with the u.n
security council and form a resolution
to be voted on by the general assembly
to issue a written condemnation using
the strongest language to scald the
taliban for their inappropriate and
frankly unpleasant and dare i say
unacceptable
conduct what else do you want
well perhaps you want instead a minimal
amount of sanity and competence from
those who lead us
on that score you're out of luck these
are after all the same people who flew
pride flags in kabul
who who tell us that the greatest terror
threat we face are parents complaining
to their school boards about masking
mandates
and a guy who stole a lectern from the
capitol building
these people who've been who've been
working diligently to instill cultural
sensitivity in our military
the people who issue military
recruitment ads that look like disney
princess films
this is what we get
this is what we get specifically from a
ruling class that is itself immersed
in leftist ideology they are they are
immersed in it the way that a man might
be immersed in lava after being thrown
into a volcano there's no rescue there's
no hope
they are consumed by this lethal
substance melting into it and becoming
eventually indistinguishable from the
substance itself
the lesson here if you hadn't learned it
by now
is that the prevailing religion of the
day in this country and across the west
the religion of leftism
is by its nature entirely detached from
and hostile to reality
this is why our leaders are incapable of
leading
they are incapable of doing anything at
all of running a city or a federal
government much less a global imperial
empire
they're limited ironically much the same
way that the taliban is limited
the taliban is frozen 1300 years in the
past doomed to live like savages and
misery and filth and to drag whatever
nation or province they run down with
them
their beliefs will not allow for peace
or advancement or flourishing
won't allow it
which means by the way um if you if you
hear because in response to the the
state department saying they need to
include women there are actually some
people at least if social media is any
indication
who who are hopeful for this because the
taliban has said and i i just saw an al
jazeera headline that was a that was uh
just published the taliban has said that
oh yeah we'll include women in the
government sure we'll do that
we're not going to kill anybody we've
turned a new leaf
and there are people taking this
seriously well hey let's give them a
chance who knows
it's not possible
okay if you're dumb enough to believe it
it's not it can't it's not it's not
possible that it's not just that it's
probably not true probably
it can't be
it won't
be their belief system will not allow it
they would have to renounce their belief
system first
now our ruling class constricted by
their own religion
driven into madness
by a worldview which militates against
truth and common sense every step of the
way
they cannot recognize this reality about
the taliban because they cannot
recognize any reality at all
they are frozen in their own way
incapacitated useless
paralyzed by their own lunacy
now it hasn't led them to the same sort
of barbaric barbarism that we see from
the taliban but it does cause different
kinds of barbarism
and not all that dissimilar in some
cases for example radical islam supports
female genital mutilation which is a
terrible thing
leftism supports the genital mutilation
of both males and females except for the
purpose of turning males into females
and vice versa
in fact the type of general mutilation
endorsed by the left
is even more barbaric and insane if such
a thing is possible
the point is that
we need to see this sort of madness from
the state department calling for
inclusivity and representation among the
taliban
in the greater context
of a government suffocated by its own
ideology presiding over a country which
is collectively choking to death from
the same cause
this is all the more reason as i argued
yesterday
why we should put our colonial dreams to
rest
i mean we're run by men who can barely
tie their own shoes
how do you expect them to rule an empire
now let's get to our five headlines
and now a word from uh one of the newer
sponsors on the show with maybe my
favorite name bio optimizer you know one
of the best things that you could
possibly do to improve your health is
get at least seven hours of quality
sleep every night uh but you know
there's there's hundreds of reasons why
you might not get enough sleep as a
father of four i have specifically four
reasons why i don't get enough sleep but
one of the biggest reasons might be
aside from having kids wake you up it
might also be magnesium deficiency you
see magnesium is key to getting good
sleep but 75 people are actually
magnesium deficient is it any wonder
then that so many people are having
sleep problems and then having all the
health problems that come from having
sleep problems so to help fix
these sleep difficulties and fully enjoy
the calming effects of magnesium check
out magnesium breakthrough by bio
optimizers it's the only organic full
spectrum magnesium supplement that
includes seven unique forms of magnesium
you gotta try this and experience the
effects for yourself magnesium
breakthrough is 100 organic and made
with vegetarian non-gmo ingredients
which is extremely important to me on a
personal level you know that so for an
exclusive offer for my listeners go to
magbreakthrough.com forward slash walsh
and use walsh 10 during checkout to save
10 off
so i got to mention this this is sad i
mean this is really sad this makes me
sad
in the same way that you know you felt
sad seeing the kid who sat alone at the
lunch table in the cafeteria in school
that kind of a pitiful kind of
sadness
um and it really ruins your lunch
honestly
to see what a loser he is so some woman
named donna provencher
who uh
i guess apparently is a journalist and
writes for the washington post or has
written for them
she tweeted this and she tagged me
um she tagged she wanted me to see this
so i feel you know to call to your
attention and publicly mock her i feel
that uh i am doing what she wanted me to
do so this is what she tweeted she says
literally the greatest birthday gift
i've ever been given honoring my
favorite hobby undermining everything
matt walsh stands for and it's a picture
of her holding a sweatshirt
that says not now sweetie
mommy's cyberbullying matt walsh and
then there's a a middle finger i guess i
don't know the middle finger is
she giving the middle finger to her kid
because she's talking to her kid in the
sweater i don't know
the point is you know i have never heard
of this person i don't know who she is
and yet i am her favorite hobby
how sad is that
and she wears my name on her body now
i will forget about her existence
shortly after we finish talking about
this
and she'll go on stewing over me
imagining that she's cyber bullying me
so this is worse than the kid at the
lunch but this is the kid at the lunch
table is sitting there alone telling
himself that he's the most popular kid
in school it's just it's it's very sad
she spent probably countless hours
apparently
tweeting at me and i never even noticed
it
well she brags to the people around her
look at me cyberbullying this guy
by the way can we just acknowledge the
elephant in the room here
like um that shirt would be pathetic no
matter whose name is on it okay
but it's worse when you put me on it
because i'm not famous enough to justify
that
so it makes it even worse there's a good
number of people who will see that
they'll have no idea who i am so you'll
have to explain
me to them you'll have to like give my
biography to them
actively tell people about me
and promote me
all to get back around to the sweatshirt
which after you explain it will seem
even lamer and weirder to the person
you're talking to than it did before you
explained it
if she walks around wearing that how
many times is she gonna be stopped and
say by people saying who's who's matt
walsh should we talk
oh he's this guy on the internet and uh
i don't like him i
i tweet mean comments to him a lot and
so i put it on a sweater
and the person will just slowly back
away
okay
all right good
good job
by the way she deleted the tweet after i
responded so that tweet has now been
deleted but um
the sweater is out there somewhere
i don't know if it's available for sale
but it's out there
okay so joe biden uh addressed the
public yesterday and gave a pretty short
speech about the situation in
afghanistan took no questions
hurried off the state well hurried as
much as he can possibly heard he kind of
shuffled off the stage afterwards took
no questions
from the press
we know that if this was if this was
trump
in a similar situation and giving a
speech
even people who hate trump would have to
acknowledge that he would have sat there
for an hour
or stood there rather taking
questions from the press
every single question
hostile to him but he would he would
have stood there
reveling in it taking the questions but
joe biden can't take any hostile
questions he's off the stage
um
the speech itself has been roundly
panned by
really everyone on all sides
and that's pretty rare that a speech
given by a politician is going to be
panned by both sides especially when
it's a democrat politician the media
hated it for the most part some
exceptions
certainly everyone on the right hated it
let's play a quick clip of uh the speech
just to get the kind of the flavor of it
here it is
i've argued for many years that our
mission should be narrowly focused on
counter-terrorism not
counter-insurgency or nation-building so
what's happened
afghanistan political leaders gave up
and fled the country
the afghan military collapsed
sometime without
trying to fight
if anything
the developments of the past week
reinforced that ending u.s military
involvement afghanistan now
was the right decision american troops
cannot
and should not
be fighting in a war and dying in a war
that afghan forces are not willing to
fight for themselves
uh i i have to tell you i feel dirty
listening to abide in speech and
agreeing with anything he says
but
i did in fact agree with those clips
there i agreed with pretty much all of
that
now that doesn't make it a good speech
okay
because for one thing in terms of
delivery you could tell that he could
barely he barely knows what he's saying
uh you could see it in his eyes you
could tell on the way he's delivering it
he's he's reading the words and it's not
registering in his brain
so that's that's a pretty big problem
um and also it was an excuse-making
speech and it it did not deal with
the real issue and the thing that has
caused uh and precipitated most of the
criticism
which is the the way that the the
withdrawal was handled the way that the
pull-out was handled
he didn't he just glossed right over
that
common political technique also pretty
smart political technique
to talk about the thing you know you're
going to talk about the thing that you
want to talk about you're going to frame
it the way you want to frame it you're
not going to talk about what your
critics are talking about
but um
we can't really call so it was it it
may or may not have been a politically
smart speech i guess we can't even call
it that because it was panned by
everybody
um there's probably no speech he could
have
given
that would have changed much of anything
for him politically
but he did avoid talking about the main
thing which is how the pull-out was
handled
and why it was handled that way
instead he's talking about why we needed
to leave
as far as that goes
the reasons that he gives
putting the the pull out to the side
the reason that he gives for leaving
that i agree with
and you know what if he had given that
exact speech six months ago and in fact
he did give almost that exact speech six
months ago when he was laying out why we
had to leave and that's i agree with it
the problem is that he's giving it again
now when that's not really the issue the
issue is the manner the manner of
leaving
but even with that acknowledged um
he he is it is true
that the afghan military gave up
the entire afghan government fled the
country
he should have known that that was going
to happen
i think he did know or at least the
people really running our government
knew that it was going to happen
should have planned for that should have
taken that into consideration
made sure that we could evacuate all of
our people beforehand before all of that
happened
but there's no but there's no getting
around the fact that they did in fact
flee the country and the afghan military
gave up
and i i don't see how
you can put all the blame on on biden
that you want fine by me
um
but i don't see how
the afghan military
escapes all blame
the way people are talking about them
it's like they're a bunch of infants
like they're toddlers oh poor afghan
military we can't expect anything from
them really we can't
300 300 000 of them supposedly
trained and equipped for 20 years
we abandoned them we bet 20 years later
we abandoned them 20 years later
that's what you call abandonment
when you're left to defend your own
country after 20 years
abandoned
now if you want to talk about abandoning
our own people on the ground and not
having a
a
plan in place to get them out yeah
there's abandonment
head should roll over that there should
be resignations over that
there should be there should be prison
sentences over that
but if you're gonna sit here and tell me
that the afghan military was abandoned
it's their country what do you mean
abandoned to their own country
if you're a military and you can't
defend your own nation after 20 years of
being
trained then whose fault is that
and i don't want to hear anything about
oh well they didn't have air support
yeah that's the point we're leaving take
care of yourself now
did the taliban have air support well
they didn't have the intelligence on the
ground how much intelligence does the
taliban have
these this sev this gang of
seventh century
savage scumbags
are they flying in there with jets
and you got you got you got a quarter
million of you and you just leave you
don't even try
even if i were to say that they're put
in a difficult situation because the our
military isn't there to guide them and
help them
fine it's a difficult spot so you don't
even try then you don't even try
is what we're being told
that's what so if you're if you're in
the military you're put a tough spot
don't even try
give in to forces that you outnumber
three or four to one
hey can we play this here here's the
taliban by the way after they took over
the presidential palace let's play this
here's them uh they're in a gym checking
out some of the gym equipment
there they are
so these are the guys that just
conquered afghanistan take a look at
this
how much are these guys benching
40 pounds maybe at most
[Music]
that dude
he's trying to
he has no idea well he's never used any
kind of
gym equipment in his life clearly
all right that guy was bicep curling
about uh about 15 pounds
and these these are the dudes there was
there was another video of them taking
over amusement park and they're like
applying on the bumper cars
and these people just conquered
afghanistan in two days
can't even say they conquered because
there was no there was no fight
it wasn't even a surrender it was just
like yeah all right you can have it
there you go country's yours
i don't i don't buy that i i don't i
don't buy absolving
you you are duty bound to defend your
own country that's why you're in the
military
absolving them of blame give me a break
come on
um
a little more afghanistan stuff here so
uh well here this is related msnbc had
an interesting way of talking about the
taliban's takeover
they said it was a peaceful takeover
much like
the blm riots
with buildings burning in the background
was actually mostly peaceful
the takeover by the taliban was also
peaceful let's play that from msnbc
hi matthew well the country is
essentially now in the hands of the
taliban for all intents and purposes uh
they've taken over kabul the president
or should i now say the former president
of afghanistan ashraf ghani has fled the
country the taliban have taken over the
presidential palace they've renamed the
country the islamic emirate taken down
the afghan flag and hoisted up
their own colors and it's been a
relatively
peaceful if you like a process they
haven't had to fire a lot of shots there
hasn't been a lot of bloodshed in kabul
it was a pretty straightforward takeover
for them
they've also taken over the airport uh
they've been reports of shots fired at
the airport and taliban fighters are are
all over the place uh but they're not in
any sort of clashes with u.s personnel
although commercial flights have so far
been suspended military evacuation
flights are still taking place and i
think from what we understand right now
most of the u.s personnel are at the
airport now trying to get on to various
uh evacuation flights out of the country
with a very few security personnel left
this embassy burning what's left of
sensitive paperwork
yeah everyone's kind of dunking on this
uh on that report from msabc saying that
it was a peaceful takeover
but actually it it it was
it doesn't mean that the taliban is
peaceful it doesn't mean that that uh
what's about to follow isn't going to be
brutal and and horrible isn't already
brutal and horrible but it is inarguably
the case that the takeover of the
country was peaceful why
as he said it wasn't that nobody fired a
shot
the country was handed over to these
people
it would have been non-peaceful
if the afghan military and government
had had any interest whatsoever in
defending their own nation
then it would have been nonpay i mean
the taliban was perfectly willing to go
in there and kill lots of people but
they didn't have to so yeah that's
actually true
that's that's look at me i'm defending
biden and msnbc that right there what
you just heard there mostly an accurate
reflection of what actually happened if
it's if it sounds outrageous to you well
it is outrageous
and you can't put all the blame on uh he
says
the only thing i take issue with is that
he says well there's there's no uh
conflicts with the us military the
military is not firing at them which is
also true but that's not the point
the issue is where's the afghan military
nowhere to be found
they ran away but you know that's all
again it's all our fault right
that no no no attempt at all to defend
their own people in their own country no
attempt zero attempt and that's our
fault
okay
sure
all right let's move on bill de blasio
has
continued making his hostage demands
hoping to brow beat new yorkers into
getting vaccinated and here's the latest
from him
as much as you want to celebrate the
city's return how concerned are you that
we're at a very precarious point on the
delta research well it's a very
important question andrew and i thank
you uh and we're always looking for that
balance
but i'll tell you something this is
absolutely strategic
to say to people
to fully participate in the life of the
city and to love and enjoy this city go
get vaccinated
we believe it's going to make a huge
impact we're obviously seeing a real
uptick in vaccinations already
we made a decision weeks and weeks ago
the whole ball game is vaccination
and
once you make that kind of profound
strategic decision you throw everything
you got at it we are not interested in
half measures we're interested in
vaccination
so making vaccinations something that
allows you to enjoy all that's good in
life
and knowing that that first dose
provides protection to begin with but
much more importantly gets you on the
road to the second dose and that's what
we see overwhelmingly that people go
back get that second dose
that's how we built this strategy so
we're watching every day
for any
areas of concern but the key is always
to move vaccination as aggressively as
possible
vaccination
is what allows you to enjoy
all that is good in life
that's an it's interesting because there
are plenty of unvaccinated people
out in the country right now who are
perfect for enjoying life quite a bit
uh having no problem enjoying all that's
good in life
so no it's not vaccination that enables
you to enjoy all that's good in life
vaccinations really has nothing to do
with it one way or another
um
it's it's more so to say bill de blasio
is declaring
that if you don't get vaccinated he has
he has created this arbitrary standard
now
and if you don't get vaccinated he will
actively try to prevent you
from enjoying all that's good in life
so that's what he should be saying if he
was being honest
if you don't get vaccinated i will try
to prevent you from enjoying your life
that is what he's saying i mean he's not
quite phrasing it that way but almost
if you don't get if you don't inject
this substance into your body
i will prevent you from enjoying life
that's what we're being told from
the mayor
of the largest city in the united states
of america allegedly a free country
inject this into your body right now
don't ask questions about it don't
question it
put it in your body or i will prevent
you from enjoying life i will take
everything from you if you don't put
this in your body right now
by the way bodily autonomy is really
important
my body my choice
in addition unrelated to that put this
in your body right now or i will or i
will strip your life of all meaning
that's what's happening in the united
states of america and it's being allowed
it's being tolerated speaking of
tolerance
um here's something on the positive end
though governor bill lee here in
tennessee we like bill lee here
and he just signed an executive order he
said no one cares more about health and
well-being of a child than a parent i'm
signing an eo today that allows parents
to opt their children out of a school
mass mandate if either a school board or
health board enacts an acts one over um
a district now here's an example
of uh of something that a governor
actually has the authority to do because
we're talking about public schools those
are government institutions run by the
state
bill lee is the governor of the state
so he's he can do this
and he's putting an executive order into
place saying hey you can
at school if you want to have a if you
want to have a mask policy that's fine
but you got to allow children and
families to opt out of it you're going
to let them make a decision
now that's called good leadership
that's called uh discernment which is
something we rarely get from our leaders
but then this from wkrn here in town
says the director of
metro nashville public schools announced
the district will continue to enforce
its mass policy despite governor bill
lee's executive order allowing parents
to opt out of mass mandates
director of schools dr adrian battle
said school districts were not notified
before the executive order was released
i don't know why that makes a difference
he said the governor's executive order
was released without prior notice to
school districts for review or comment
as such metro schools will continue to
require face masks pursuant to the rules
adopted by the board as we further
review this order and explore all the
options available to the district to
best protect the health of our students
teachers and staff well they need to
further review the order okay what is
there to review it's pretty short it's
like one paragraph
and all it says is uh you can't force
people to wear masks they can opt out
that's it there's not a lot to review
the nashville school board says well we
got we had to take some a moment here
really study this thing
you need about we need about five six
seven weeks
got to go through this line by line it's
very it's very complex
oh really what they're saying is oh i
don't care what you say governor
we're a public school we're run by the
state you're the governor of the state
but i i don't give a damn what you say
we're going to do what we want
try and stop us what are you going to do
send the state police in
start cart the school board off to jail
sounds good to me personally
i doubt that's gonna happen
see this is how um
this is how democrats operate
assuming that the people running
national public schools are all
democrats which i'd say is a pretty safe
assumption at least 98 democrat because
this is this is how they operate they
say no we don't
we don't care about the law we don't
care about authority we don't care about
anything we don't care about any of that
chain of command doesn't matter
we're going to do what we want to do try
and stop us
an attitude an approach that i wish uh
republicans would consider adopting
every once in a while and finally one
other thing on uh
on masking in schools and everything
else
eric feigl ding who's an epidemiologist
and a trusted one of those trusted
experts of the expert class posted this
video of a teacher crying about going
back to school
and uh if this sounds like something
that you may have heard last year
well yeah it is exactly like last year
but this is this year now the teachers
are still crying and saying they
shouldn't have to go back to school
they want two years now if school's
being shut down
and uh she's crying about going much
like a child might cry about going back
to school so is this teacher and here's
what she has to say
i have had my regular back-to-school
anxieties things like am i going to have
enough time am i going to get my lessons
done are the students going to be okay
but this year
there is this
overshadowing apprehension that's
clouding my normal back to school
thoughts
it's with
it's with thoughts like
if i die
who's going to take care of my children
and if i end up in the hospital how am i
going to pay those bills
and if i give covet to my students
or my own children
and they die
how am i going to live with that
and i want you to ask any teacher
how they feel this year and i'm sure
that they will tell you that they have
never experienced anxiety like this
never experienced anxiety like this
except for last year
right because the teachers love talking
about their anxiety this never no one
has ever suffered like we are suffering
we're being
we're being told to go to go to work
you want us to do our
jobs this is unimaginable
meanwhile almost the rest of society has
been going to work and doing their jobs
for some people the this the entire time
never
stopped
almost everyone else now is back on the
job
working around people
doing you know doing what they're
supposed to do
except the teachers
they they refuse no it's to send them
back is a
is a
horrible oppression
you know i see a video like that and it
does upset me it does upset and it does
distress me to see her tears
because i am upset to think
and to realize once again
that our t that our kids are being
taught
by such
self-serving selfish narcissistic morons
that is what is upsetting to me
to see an idiot like this
and that that is the
the the amount of contempt at this point
that we should heap on teachers who are
still crying about having to do their
jobs get another job lady if you still
do was that what you really want you
want two years of the kids not in school
because of your unreasonable
paranoid psychotic
delusional fear
get another job
please
there's 10 million of them available you
could go do anything else we're also
told all the time that teachers are
underpaid they don't get paid a lot so
you should be able to go and find a
better paying job
leave the kids alone please
you don't want to go back to the job to
work we don't want you back at work
all right before we get to reading the
comments here uh
i also want to play this for you this is
this is another football related item we
had one yesterday
about tim tebow who by the way i just
saw before we started shooting tim tebow
is
was cut by the jacksonville jaguars so
there was a lot of controversy
that we talked about yesterday tim tebow
in his first uh preseason game the fact
that he was on the field at all was very
upsetting for people in sports media
they said what about colin kaepernick
and now he's been cut from the team
and i'm sure that will not stop the
claims of racism all the people who said
that it's racist that tim tebow's given
this opportunity
colin kaepernick wasn't
are they going to go back around and
apologize and say oh well i guess this
wasn't a racist conspiracy i mean they
cut him after all i guess they were just
given a chance to try out he wasn't good
enough they let him go
i doubt they'll apologize
uh another football related item the nfl
has added a new point of emphasis for
refs this year uh taunting is a point of
emphasis that's always been against the
rules but now it's a point of emphasis
which means that they're going to be
throwing a lot of flags for it
uh players who taunt will get a 15-yard
penalty and we saw what this will look
like during the colts pre-season game on
sunday go ahead and play this this clip
here
this is the colts preseason game
um
well you see a great run here
against the panthers
this guy is dragging
tractor pull right there there's the
taunt and he gets the 15-yard penalty
first of all he drags like 10 guys about
10 yards grit's a great run and he's
excited he's pumped up he gets up
and he just flexes for like a second
and kind of and says something to the
guy on the ground and they throw a 15
penalty that's a flag
and this is this is evidence of two
things which which is a problem in
football first of all the people who
work in football are constantly trying
to convince themselves that football is
more serious than it is they want to
convince themselves because they've
given their life to this and so they
want to convince themselves that it's
more than just a child's game which is
what it is
why shouldn't you taunt it's a game
they're playing a game that's all
they're they're on they're on a grassy
field trying to get the ball across a
line
it's a game
it's a fun game i like watching it but
it is a game
well we can't have any of that in
football this is this is we need
professionalism do we
in a game why
and also you see the same issue that you
find with any bureaucracy
and the nfl is a bureaucracy
you know a non-governmental bureaucracy
where you have a bunch of people
constantly trying to justify their jobs
because in any bureaucracy whether it's
in the nfl or the federal bureaucracy if
you're actually at any level
um you know like 80 of the people
there
shouldn't have jobs at all they really
have nothing to do
so what they're always trying to do
their their real job whatever their
whatever their job their official job
title is doesn't matter their real job
is to constantly justify the fact that
they have a job
and so they're always looking for
problems to solve
for things to do
and that's the nfl so this year here's a
problem
guys saying mean things
to other guys on the nfl field
that's a problem you know that'll
that'll justify our jobs for another
year and we'll find a new problem next
year
that's why bureaucracies function all
right moving on now to reading the
comments this is from mark says
hilarious and pathetic that matt
who was prime aged to serve after 9 11
but didn't
accursing the afghans of being cowards i
guess he means accusing
maybe a cursing would work too accusing
the afghans of being cowards i served in
afghanistan as well as iraq and had the
honor of serving alongside many many
brave and honorable afghan soldiers and
prosecutors they risked their lives
fighting al qaeda and its allies unlike
matt also we weren't fighting in
afghanistan because it was noble we were
there because it was in the us's
interest well mark
i thank you for your service first of
all i mean that sincerely
i will say that i was 15 on 9 11 so a
little young to serve at that point
by the time i was of age we had been
mired in iraq for
no justifiable reason and thousands of
young men were dying because of lies
told by our intelligence agencies
um
and we at that point by the time i
graduated i guess we'd been in iraq for
about a year um and no i didn't really
want to get involved in that i admit
i respect everyone who did join i admire
you grateful for you
um but no i never i never i never felt
that i was
duty-bound
to go fight in
um
or afghanistan and if our country has
ever invaded
and my family and my community is
threatened
then yes i will be duty bound to defend
them
um
i feel confident that i would defend
them because simply for the fact that
i'd rather be dead than allow harm to
come to my family
and that's not a close call for me but
if i did slink away like a coward which
is kind of what you're
insinuating here if i did
if i were to run and abandon those who
need me in this time of need abandon my
country
to the barbarian hordes at the gate
then yes i would not only be a coward
but a hypocrite and no man at all
that would be absolutely true
maybe you're right that i am that
i don't think i am but
okay whatever
none of that changes the facts as far as
afghanistan goes
none of that changes the facts
what
my my personal character does not change
the facts
so i'm going to allow you to make any
assumptions about that that you want
doesn't it change the facts on the
ground
it especially doesn't change the most
basic fact
that a nation must be able to
sustain and defend itself
and the army of a particular nation
has the foremost responsibility to
defend that nation
the foremost responsibility for
defending a nation cannot fall on the
army of a different country
superseding the responsibility of the
army of that country
that's my basic point
it's certainly not an
anti-us military point
quite the opposite
i'm saying i don't want to i don't want
to see any more of our young men
some of our best
sent over to that
god forsaken desert
to defend a country that has no interest
in existing
okay let's see
evan says matt if every single job
involves working with incompetent
workers as you claimed
would you mind giving us a list of the
incompetent people who work at the daily
wire
well look um
all i'm gonna say
and this is true
is that last week i asked for an
espresso to be made
and brought to my desk and five minutes
later it had not been brought
and i had to ask twice
so
first of all do never claim that i don't
suffer
and that's all i'm going to say about
that
let's see
tony says for someone that doesn't do
foreign coverage matt you're spot on so
many good points i hadn't even thought
about
maybe you should do more of this
i i hope not i mean right now we sort of
have no choice but to talk about these
kinds of issues because it's it's
the only thing that anybody is talking
about but uh as i said as i began the
show talking about yesterday
um
my focus is on what's happening in this
country and the things especially that
that affect american families and i
think that's what all of our focus
should be
um another comment says dress your truth
matt be stunning and brave with your
wardrobe so some some some uh supportive
comments for my tan on tan look which i
was being cyber bullied for
i get i guess i get cyber bullied a lot
maybe my
you know who should
who should be wearing that sweater i
showed you before my wife
she is the one who does all the
cyberbullying
she is my most dedicated cyberbully
and i tell you if i got her that sweater
for her it really would be the greatest
gift ever
let's see
blake says my two-year-old son is in
speech therapy and i worry that he won't
succeed as well due to the masks his
therapist even said it's harder to teach
speaking skills with most of their face
covered
and i hate to hear that and of course
that is absolutely true though
um
especially i mean in speech therapy
they're making them wear the mask i
shouldn't be surprised i kind of am
that it's almost impossible to do
when you're you're taking the visual
cues away we don't think about it we
don't we we as adults who have fully
developed language skills some of us
anyway uh we don't really think about
the visual cues that are involved in
verbal communication but they're there
and early on in the learning stage
especially for a child who has some some
developmental struggles to take that
away is really unpickable and finally
another comment says af is internet
shorthand for as foretold
your wife is well within her rights to
cyberbully you
well i don't know about that um so af is
as foretold i'm skeptical i mean you
could be right you could be
but i don't know if the kids really use
the phrase as foretold enough to need a
shorthand for it
maybe they're big fans of biblical
prophetic literature i don't know
i'll try dropping that at church on
sunday and i'll let you know how it goes
well i don't have to fake excitement
about this one not that i faked about
anything else because i'm always excited
about reading all the ads as you know
this one though is a totally different
deal okay this is an ad you need to
listen to
um the sweet baby gang i don't have to
tell you about it you know about it i
don't have to explain it to you because
i can't even really explain it to be
honest with you uh the sweet baby gang
we are in the need in need of an anthem
we need a song that encapsulates
everything that the sweet baby gang is
which first you have to figure out what
it is in order to encapsulate in a song
so it's a pretty big project uh and
that's why right now we are accepting
official submissions for the sweet baby
gang anthem all submissions should be in
the form of a youtube video uh on a link
and it will be judged by american uh
it'd be just sort of american idol style
by myself and other daily wire hosts who
have been roped into this thing to take
part in it um and and also you the
winner will you the viewer will
ultimately decide who the winner is so
to enter go to dailywire.com
sbg dailywire.com sbg again you got to
do a youtube video you have to have the
link submit the link and submissions end
on august 25th
and i think all the other we're forcing
the other hosts to read this and talk
about the sweet baby gang which is maybe
the best part about this that they have
to read it
and um
which is great all right
also not as exciting but still pretty
exciting some of you listening may be
sitting on the fence about joining the
daily wire if you haven't heard of our
reader's pass it's a great bargain for
the content for just four bucks a month
the daily wire readers pass unlocks
exclusive editorial content that unpacks
trending political and cultural topics
penned by everyone from ben shapiro to
dan crenshaw and most importantly me
it's only four dollars a month and you
get the readers pass you get all that
content so you got to do that also
candace owens never fails to be one of
the most talked about figures on twitter
and if you want to see her live in
person rather than just being quote
tweeted tweeted by
quote tweeted we'll just leave that in
quote tweeted by angry leftists i've got
great news for you if you sign up now as
a daily wire member with code vip you'll
get 25 off your new membership and be
automatically entered for a chance to
win a trip for two
for you and a guest to the daily wire
studios to see candace live not only
will you meet candace but you'll also
get an inside look at her studio front
row seats to watch her take down leftist
live and in action on her talk show
candace so go to dailywire.com subscribe
with code vip and get 25
off now my sweet sweet babies let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
well with all the major world events
currently unfolding you may have missed
this story even though it has been
dutifully reported by all of our
major media outlets as nbc tells us the
singer lizzo has tearfully called out
fat phobic and racist hate directed
towards her newsweek buffing to post the
la times daily beast many other sources
have issued their own reports on this
subject apparently in a recent instagram
live video lizzo began crying about the
internet trolls who are mean to her
accused them of racism and fat phobia
and complained about the deep impact
that these that these random anonymous
accounts have had on her self-esteem
now i'm sure you'll already agree that
this was of course a newsworthy event
but here's a little bit of that video
just so you can fully appreciate the
scope and implication of this issue here
it is
i have people who have something
something mean to say about you
and for the most part it doesn't hurt my
i
feelings
care
i just think when
i'm working this hard my
my tolerance gets lower
my patience is lower i'm more sensitive
and it gets to me
you know we're meant to feel quite bad
for lizzo in fact we've been sternly
instructed to feel bad for her a post on
jezebel says that her tears are so pure
her heartache is so deep and profound
that we quote don't deserve lizzo's
tears
i don't really know what that means but
i'm sure it meant something to the
person who wrote it a writer for
refinery29 explains that quote lizzo's
joy her steadfast belief and her right
to exist and fully occupy spaces upsets
people who bought into the white
supremacist lie that these things black
bodies and radical beliefs must shrink
lizzo is beautiful well resourced and
has millions of fans listening to her
reclaim her space
once again that doesn't appear to really
mean anything
is there a white supremacist conspiracy
to shrink black bodies
has rick moranis turned into a neo-nazi
and begun using his powers for evil i'm
not sure but the point we're supposed to
take away from this is that um
yes that was a honey i shrunk the kids
reference kids you might you're too
young for that
um
lizzo is is a victim that's the point
he's she is an injured precious flower
and this is all a major problem for the
world actually her tearful complaints
about mean internet comments are sort of
interesting when you compare them to the
song she just released called rumors now
in the video for that song she twerks in
a skin-tight suit while boasting that
her body is goals meaning that her body
is so beautiful that other people want
to look just like her you know they have
a goal to look just like her and she
brags about walking around with quote
her ass hanging out
now i know that you're you're hoping
desperately that i will let you see and
hear all of this for yourself and you're
in luck because here it
[Music]
me and cardi is cool yeah i love volvos
yeah i am bodyguards yeah
from my soul yeah black people may rock
and roll yeah
why are you spending all your time
trying to break a woman
take a look around if you thought
[Music]
so there you go
unironically i will say that the song is
powerful and i don't mean powerful in
the sense that the odor from an
overflowing garbage can baking in the
sun is powerful though it is powerful in
that sense as well and there's no doubt
that it is a powerfully awful garbage
song and part of the music industry's
increasingly successful plot to make
everybody dumber but when i say powerful
i mean really that there are some
important lessons we can learn from all
of this the first is that
if you don't want people
making comments about your body
don't run around half naked
while insisting that everybody look at
your body okay it's a fact of life that
if you purposefully put an intimate
aspect of yourself on display to the
world you are going to hear the world's
opinions about it don't want the world's
opinions keep it to yourself
you might say that the world should have
better manners
you know and maybe maybe it should but
it doesn't at a certain point you need
to start operating within reality as it
is actually constructed also
manners run both ways it is bad manners
to walk around with your quote ass
hanging out in lizzo's words and in fact
when you do that
and you call attention to it
and you say hey everybody look my ass is
hanging out the people who have been
subjected to that site are i would say
not only within their rights but within
the bounds of proper etiquette to say
something like wow gross can you please
stop that
the idea that people have today is that
they should have the right to flaunt
themselves their bodies their personal
lives every personal detail about them
revealing every crack and crevice of
themselves to the public if you'll
pardon the phrase and that they should
also get to determine how the public
reacts to that ghastly spectacle
but it doesn't work that way
and again this is not only about showing
off your body these days people like to
show off many other things all of the
most personally intimate details about
them and then become deeply traumatized
when strangers honestly react to it
they want us to know their business
but also to stay out of their business
it is schizophrenic and ridiculous
also there's something else
note how lizzo fronts as this confident
body positive boisterous bold
self-esteem warrior and yet in reality
breaks down in tears because a few
random people on the internet insulted
her
i mean lizzo is roundly praised almost
everywhere by almost everyone she's rich
and famous beloved highly acclaimed
she's won awards she's run she's won
commendations of all kinds the entire
media is ready to print headlines
congratulating her or consoling her
whatever she needs
she lives in this echo chamber of
adulation and yet crumbles if the
slightest criticism leaks through the
cracks
now some of us like yours truly are also
very harshly judged and criticized on
the internet and yet are certainly not
engulfed in flattery nearly to the same
extent
and
we don't cry over mean comments
least of all would we cry publicly live
streaming it for the world to see
so what's going on here
well this is more evidence of what
should already be obvious
the body positivity stuff
the self-esteem on steroids stuff the
look at me i'm so beautiful and awesome
posturing that you get from pop stars
and from normal people also in this
culture these days that's all an act
it's all a form of overcompensation a
way to disguise their crippling
insecurities
people don't go around showing off their
bodies flaunting themselves talking
about how great and amazing and
beautiful they are if they are actually
confident in themselves
people
wear normal clothing and go about their
day
they are body positive in the sense that
they don't spend an exorbitant amount of
time thinking about their bodies
they are not immersed in thoughts about
their own bodies
and they certainly don't need you to
think about their bodies
so what we call body positivity is
actually body affirmation the people who
constantly announce to the world that
they're body positive are actually
saying that they need affirmation they
need you to notice them and then notice
their bodies and respond in a certain
way
they say they don't care they don't care
about anybody's opinion but but
literally the exact opposite is true
there is nothing they value more than
everybody's opinion
they live for your approval they need it
like they need air and water
but putting lizzo's specific case aside
for a moment
i think it's interesting to think about
how we got to this point where so many
people are so totally dependent upon
public affirmation and approval
we've talked about that problem quite a
bit
how do we get here why is it like this
well i think one obvious culprit is the
internet you know as most kids grow up
on the internet
are raised by the internet in many ways
they become conditioned to this
environment where everything you do and
say is a public spectacle and you
receive an immediate judgment from your
audience
you do something say something post
something and your audience responds
right away with either applause or
affirmation
jeers or disapproval thumbs up or thumbs
down
nice comments or mean comments
jerry seinfeld once said that when he's
on the stage he gets a performance
review every 30 seconds because the
crowd laughs at the joke or not
and so it's different from other you
know kinds of jobs where you get a
performance review every month or
whatever
and when you're on the stage it's like
it's an immediate thing
the feedback is also blunt right
well now everybody is on a stage of
sorts our kids grow up on one
where they receive those rapid fire
performance reviews every hour of every
day they become conditioned to depend on
those reviews always seeking the
dopamine hit that comes with a positive
evaluation
and because they live for positive
feedback their greatest fear is
criticism negative feedback
criticism starts to feel almost like a
almost like a physical danger something
that threatens to undermine their very
existence
now if this sounds like a horrible way
to condition children
and like a recipe for a society full of
fragile non-functioning crybabies well
welcome to america circa 2021
lizzo is the poster child for everything
that has just been described which
explains her popularity but also
explains why she is today
finally canceled
again i think i think this is like the
third time
hasn't set in yet we'll keep going
that'll do it for us today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
2021
msnbc calls the taliban takeover
peaceful cnn dubs the terrorists
friendly and joe biden blames everybody
but himself for the collapse of
afghanistan check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]